vous êtes un cadeau du ciel monsieur clé
ce terrain était à l'abandon vous lui
avez redonné vie
c'est la seule personne qui est jamais
veillée sur moi je vois un message qui
dit qu'il y a un problème avec mon
ordinateur
et c'est enlevé la vie hier c'est une
propriété privée ici vous savez ce
qu'ils font ici ils arnaque les gens les
plus faibles je vais compter jusqu'à 3 1
2 3
voilà je l'ai fait pour vous
[Musique]
quoi pour le foot dehors
vous me dites que seul l'homme a fait ça
et tout ce que vous savez c'est que
c'est un apiculteur
ce genre d'apiculteur
les apiculteurs sont des agents secrets
indépendants de tous les services je
protège la ruche quand il y a un
déséquilibre
je rectifie il y a des lois pour ces
choses là quand elles ne sont pas
appliquées je m'en occupe
[Musique]
mes doigts il les a coupé
tout ça c'est bien plus que du simple à
son âge
l'argent est envoyé partout dans le
monde à des gens en finance mais aussi à
des gouvernements
[Musique]
toi tu es un problème tu peux être sûr
que
je me suis dit que je prendrai le relève
des pompiers quelqu'un peut arrêter ce
gars
nous devons le tuer alors qu'il ne tue
assez de gens pour se rendre au sommet
c'est inflammable
c'est